hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today i'm
going to explain a 2017 russian science
fiction and action movie called
attraction
the movie begins with yulia daughter of
one of the leaders in the russian
military who shares a story about her
deceased mother and her loneliness
despite living with her father during
the classroom the teacher is explaining
about an astronomical phenomenon
happening on earth and a nerd named
google seems to have a crush on julia
since he always tries to help her to
answer the teacher's questions
after school julia asks her father
colonel valentin lebedev permission to
see a meteor shower that evening but he
forbids the request claiming it's for
her safety annoyed with her dad's
decision she calls her badass boyfriend
tyoma who suggests she disobeys her
father since it is a once in a 50 years
phenomenon tyoma eventually picks yulia
up to the roof of a building where
everyone is waiting for the meteor
shower while yulia meets her girlfriend
svetlana the couple decide to have fun
in svetlana's apartment room leaving her
alone on the rooftop
meanwhile an alien spaceship is seen
traveling through the solar system
suddenly it gets hit by one of the
meteors causing it to malfunction and
enter earth's atmosphere at a very high
speed the russian military detects the
falling alien spaceship and they launch
missiles at it since it does not slow
down causing it to lose speed the
spaceship begins to fall toward the city
and damages several buildings including
svetlana's apartment this collision
immediately kills svetlana while shocks
the couple who almost fall from the
building after crashing a lot of
buildings and killing hundreds of people
it finally stops moving the russian
military immediately approaches the
crashing ship in the impact zone and
attempts to make contact with them while
evacuating the city since the spaceship
could be a nuclear bomb colonel lebedev
and mikhail polskin a state duma deputy
walk toward the ship to make contact
with an ancient creature presumably
alien for the first time
several shooters are also placed to
anticipate a surprise attack mchale
attempts to give a warm welcome to the
alien and it seems to understand them
and try to communicate with them but in
an unidentified language
a few moments later lebedev reports to
the higher-ups saying that he has an
agreement with the aliens to keep a
distance from them while they are
repairing the broken spaceship
some higher-ups suggest they carry out
an assault to destroy it entirely but
the colonel refuses to provoke
aggression with the aliens and chooses
to observe
meanwhile yulia finally awakens and
learns that her girlfriend has passed
away she also sees the news on the tv
revealing that his father is responsible
for the operation and protective
structures that have been built around
the one kilometer radius surrounding the
spaceship
she then leaves the hospital and mourns
for her friend's death colonel lebedev
then takes his daughter home where she
has to live with her grandma temporarily
despite the crash the students still
attend school where the teacher
expresses his excitement to encounter an
extraterrestrial civilization the
students are angry towards the aliens
since they believe the aliens are the
cause of the death of their friends or
family members and the military still
doesn't take any action yulia then
secretly takes her father's gun and goes
to tayoma's gang hideout where tyoma and
his friends plan to spread negative
comments about the aliens in the social
media she urges them to go to the
quarantine zone to avenge her
girlfriend's death they sneak in through
an old processing plant and eventually
arrive at the zone tyoma suggests yulia
waits in the car while the others
explore the nearby buildings where they
discover an alien thing presumably fell
through the ceiling
meanwhile yulia disobeys her boyfriend
and silently ascends to svetlana's
apartment room where an alien creature
suddenly shows up and shocks yulia the
alien saves her from falling down and
tries to communicate with her while
tyoma and his friends arrive and hit the
mysterious creature it slips and loses
his grip causing it to free fall they
immediately approach the creature and
tyoma finds blood which has the same
characteristics as humans turns out that
it is an exoskeleton armor and yulia
spots a dying alien creature which has
the exact same physical form as humans
but she ignores him they then manage to
take the armor and mysterious thing away
unnoticed
later that night yulia can't sleep and
decides to go back to the building in
the quarantine zone
upon arrival she rescues the alien and
hides its body inside the car the next
day she asks google who plans to study
medicine after graduation to help her
she tells google that she owes the alien
and wants to save him google concludes
his anatomy as similar to humans thus
they bring him to a hospital since he
has lost a lot of blood they do a blood
test on him and figure out that he has
the same blood group with yulia she
decides to transfuse her blood to him
and it works he wakes up and suddenly
grabs her hand transferring his mental
bracelet to her while taking a bath she
realizes that the metal bracelet
attracts water and allows her to control
water
meanwhile the military army retrieves
the shield look-alike alien thing and
investigates it the colonel is also
aware that the thing can control water
on the other side a fisherman is shocked
when he finds out the water nearby the
alien vessel has magically disappeared
the scientist concludes that the ship
draws water and uses it to fix the ship
since 30 percent of the external damage
of the ship has been repaired meanwhile
the alien wakes up and somehow manages
to speak russian he introduces himself
as haikon and reveals that he is looking
for a device called shulk he dresses up
and leaves on his own the patrolling
officer spot him and send him off to a
police station to be interrogated
taiyoma and his friends examine the
exoskeleton and discover that they can
utilize it since it is the right size
for humans one of his friends
accidentally activates the armor which
makes the gang panic
tyoma calls colonel lebadev and decides
to hand over the exoskeleton to the
military but he is not available at the
moment they stumble upon a crowd who are
furious because the military rationed
the water supply one of them attempts to
provoke the crowd and the fight between
the officers and the crowd ensues tyoma
who has good intentions to try to break
up the fight gets hit in the back by one
of the officers and gets arrested not
long after lebedev arrives but tyoma
cancels his plan to give the exoskeleton
to the military while being questioned
the police officer is confused when she
cannot find any fingerprints on heikon's
finger a few moments later yulia arrives
at the police station to free haycon
unfortunately tyoma is also in the same
room when he finds yulia and he is very
disappointed with her action she decides
to bring the alien to the perimeter to
meet her father while on their way
haikon explains that he needs shilt to
be able to return to his planet upon
arrival yulia has to lie that she is
pregnant so that her father wants to
meet her she introduces haycon to the
colonel while silently takes her
father's access card and gives it to the
alien who is sent out by the enraged
father haikon disguises as a scientist
and sneaks into the laboratory where he
retrieves the shield from the
unidentified thing it takes some time
before the scientists realize that he is
not colonel lebadev they immediately
trigger the emergency alarm
afterwards heikon somehow reunites with
yulia and lebedev who orders his men to
drive them home
tyoma is finally released and with his
friends they start preparing for the
revolt they modify their car make
molotovs and supply baseball bats after
that he calls yulia and apologizes
begging her to join the movement but she
refuses as she chooses the alien over
him haikon needs to bring the shilk into
the ship immediately but they have to
wait until midnight since there's no way
they can pass the guards there she
brings him home and introduces her sick
dog to the alien haycon understands that
the dog is suffering thus he brings the
shield closer to the dog which magically
cures his sickness and the dog has now
become healthy again
while eating yulia learns from the tv
that heikon has now become a military
fugitive discovering her dad with his
military convoy arrives at home they run
away where haikon warns her not to smoke
since it is harmful for her health
meanwhile the hate video towards the
alien and military has now gone viral
and affects a lot of people the video
suggests that humans must protect their
earth from the superior beings
turns out that it's tyoma and his
friends who create and post the video to
spread hate yulia and haikon visit
google and borrow his clothes afterwards
the pair go to a concert where colonel
lebedev can't look for them while
dancing heikon tells yulia to hold his
hand and shows her what his planet looks
like he says that humans are prohibited
to get closer to their ship or saul will
destroy the ship since they are afraid
that humans will steal their advanced
technology unfortunately one of tayoma's
friends spots them and directly informs
them which makes tyoma enraged after the
party yulia escorts the alien back to
his ship through the abandoned building
where they finally kiss and yulia
confesses her true feelings to the alien
suddenly the broken-hearted tyoma and
his friends appear and start beating up
the alien ruthlessly haikon decides to
fight back when tyoma slaps yulia he
shows his superiority and knocks
everyone down easily one of the men
attempts to shoot heikon but the bullet
hits ruslan instead tayoma and his
friend managed to flee when the guards
arrive taioma who was devastated because
his best friend was killed orders his
friend to spread the fake news telling
that the alien has killed the man and
invites everyone on the internet to riot
and attack the spaceship after everyone
is gathered tyoma gives a provocative
speech to them telling them that the
military has been protecting the aliens
not them and they have to reclaim their
earth the military holds the fire and
chooses to defend the line but tyoma's
group begins to rampage and manages to
break through the barricade meanwhile
tyoma tries to utilize the alien's
exoskeleton
feeling threatened the spaceship summons
several aliens with the modern suit to
defend their ship at the military base
yulia reveals to her father that heikon
is not human and eventually disobeys her
father threatening to kill herself since
she believes that the right thing to do
right now is to return the alien to his
ship instead of calling a full military
assault she immediately drives heikon
back to his spaceship where tyoma with
his new suit intervenes he crashes the
car causing yulia to faint heikon has no
other option than to fight him tyoma
outpowers the alien and attempts to kill
him when yulia wakes up and hits the
exoskeleton with the car
meanwhile colonel lebedev and his
soldiers lower their weapons showing to
the aliens that they are harmless the
exoskeleton loses its arm and tyoma is
ejected from the suit he grabs the rifle
and ruthlessly shoots the couple
lebedev sees his daughter get shot and
immediately orders his men to arrest
tyoma the aliens cooperate with the
humans and bring the dying haikon yulia
and colonel lebedev into the ship they
then put them into a healing capsule
while lebedev talks to the ship's a.i
saul
saul who speaks russian explains to the
colonel that they are prohibited to
visit earth since it's considered as a
place with an extremely aggressive
social environment haikon believes there
is hope to make contact with earth and
travels to earth to observe thanks to
yulia's sincere love for hakon saul
states that she might bring a positive
impact to the result of the observation
not long after yulia is resurrected and
the spaceship departs from earth while
releasing excess water
at the end of the movie yulia states
that one stranger and the far distant
cosmos believed in humankind
capabilities more than humans themselves
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching